محنه فاخرى ما ابقته الحرب نسفه الزلزال
ترتبط المحنتان ايضا في كون الاولى اوجدت
واقعا في الشمال السوري عقد تبعات التاليه
حتى قبل ان تهتز الارض هنا كان ما يزيد
على اربعه ملايين شخص بتقدير الامم
المتحده بحاجه الى المساعدات والان تتعثر
جهود ايصال ما يلزم من مساعدات انسانيه
الى المتضررين من الزلزال في حينها ودون
عوائق
الامم المتحده نفسها تقر بالفشل في ايصال
المساعدات الحيويه مع ان لديها اليه واضحه
في هذا الشان
ففي مناطق سيطره المعارضه السوريه
المحاذيه لتركيا مع براني حدوديان رئيسيه
هما باب الهوى في ادلب وقد جدد مجلس الامن
الشهر الماضي التفويض الامميه لدخول
المساعدات عبره سته اشهر اخرى
ومعبر باب السلامه في ريف حلب المغلق منذ
سنوات لعدم تجديد التفويض وثمه معابر اخرى
مدنيه تجاريه كما تسمى هي اقل تجهيزا
كجرابلس والراعي والحمام
في الجانب التركي المنشغل بمصابه تثار
مساله الاضرار التي طاولت شبكه الطرق
باتجاه الحدود الجنوبيه مع سوريا لتفسير
بطء الجهد لغاثي تبدو لافته للنظر دعوه
واشنطن مجلس الامن للموافقه الفوريه على
ارسال مزيد من المساعدات الدوليه الى
المنكوبين في شمال غربي سوريا عبر تركيا
وهنا ترى الامم المتحده الحله في فتح مزيد
من المعابر ونقاط ايصال المساعدات للاشد
حاجه اليها في الشمال السوري وتقول نائبه
المنفذ الاممي الخاص الى سوريا نجاه رشدي
في تغريده على تويتر ان المساعده عبر
الحدود هي شريان الحياه للاشخاص في شمال
غربي سوريا وان السوريين بحاجه الى مساعده
عاجله
الطريقه الاخرى لادخال المساعدات
الانسانيه الاماميه هي ما يعرف بخطوط
التماس اظهرت جهود قليله بذلت في هذا
الاتجاه منذ وقوع الزلزال كيف ان العمليه
صعبه ومحفوفه بالمخاطر بنسبه لنظام السوري
لا مشكله كما يقول في ايصال المساعدات
الانسانيه حتى الى المناطق الخارجه عن
سيطرته
كما يحددها المنسق الاممي للشؤون
الانسانيه في سوريا هي الحاجه الى موافقات
لدخول مناطق شمال غربي سوريا ليس جرافيث
اول مسؤول في الامم المتحده يتحدث عن عدم
السماح بادخال اي مساعدات في مناطق التماس
بين النظام والمعارضه ولا اول من امتنع عن
تحديد الجهات التي لم تصدر الاذن المطلوب